good day and welcome i'm jack van horn from the
university of virginia please allow me to welcome
you to this edition of our 2020 2021 foundations
of biomedical data science seminar series
our speaker today is dr lucina uddin she
is associate professor at the university
of miami where she's also the director of the
cognitive and behavioral neuroscience division
in 2001 she completed her bachelor of science
degree in neuroscience and philosophy at the
university of california in los angeles
and completing her phd work in cognitive
and psycho psychological neuroscience at the
university of california los angeles in 2006.
her professional experience includes postdoctoral
fellows fellowships at new york university and
stanford university and since 2014 has been
a faculty member at the university of miami
at miami she leads the brain connectivity and
cognition laboratory which employs neuroimaging
and accompanying methods to examine the
relationship between brain connectivity and
cognition in typical and atypical development many
of her her long list of accomplishments includes
the university of miami de belli senior scholar
award uh the universal scientific education and
research network laureate in medical sciences
the organization for human brain mappings young
investigator award and several others her lecture
today is entitled neuroinformatics and cognitive
ontologies and we are very excited to welcome
her to our our series now before we begin as
you uh as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube if you are
watching on youtube thank you for joining us
uh also our specially selected uh 2020 2021
uh biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are encouraged to submit any
questions for dr uddin via the
chat feature of their zoom sessions
i'll synthesize these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of dr uddin's talk with that welcome lucina we
are very much looking forward to your election
thanks very much uh dr van horn it's really a
pleasure to be here virtually with all of you
um share some of our work in this area and i
do wish i could be there in person for all of
these different activities but um until then the
virtual format will have to do so um what i'd like
to share with you today is just some some thoughts
and some data about the topic of neuroinformatics
and cognitive ontologies so for those of us
working in cognitive neuroscience we know that
there have been decades and decades of fmri
functional magnetic resonance imaging work
that's identified distinct patterns of brain
activation that occur while participants perform
different kinds of cognitive tests and the goal of
course is to map the areas of the brain that are
involved in different types of cognitive processes
um sort of the goal of cognitive neuroscience
very broadly and what we would like to suggest
here today is that these data can in principle
be used to provide the basis for constructing
a biologically informed data-driven ontology or
taxonomy of psychological processes and there's
many others who've worked in this area too over
the years and i'll draw on some of that literature
as well so in this talk i'd like to highlight some
of the progress and challenges associated with
the construction of cognitive ontologies using
informatics approaches and based on functional
neuroimaging data so let me go the right direction
let's see okay so what is a cognitive ontology um
so an ontology generally is a branch of philosophy
that deals with the nature and organization
of reality so what things are there in the
world out there how do we carve up nature at its
joints that's really what ontology deals with
um and so a cognitive ontology then would
be a formal description of concepts that are
assumed to exist within a particular domain
here we're talking about psychology and the
interrelationships between them so uh one sort of
easy way of thinking about ontologies is just what
are the knowledge structures that we you know know
about uh that we use to communicate amongst each
other so you know we just saw the the nba finals
with the the lakers uh coming out as champs again
um and if you think about an ontology of the nba
you have things like basic units like players that
belong to teams and you have a western conference
in an eastern conference and knowing this
knowledge structure tells you that in the finals
you're going to have a team from the west play
a team from the east because that's the structure
of the nba and knowing all the things we do about
teams and their compositions and the players
that make them up it tells us something about
what we can expect um in any uh you know given
category to contain so just knowledge of the
way the nba works is a particular ontology and
just like that we we had these sort of knowledge
structures in in various domains so you know in
the case of of cognitive ontology we might uh
think about something like a particular task
um and how we should categorize that so many
people use these simple task paradigms the flanker
task is one in which the participant is asked look
at the arrow in the center and tell me if it's
pointing to the left or pointing to the right and
you use a button press to indicate your response
and the challenge of this task is sometimes
there's flankers to that central arrow going in
opposite direction and um you know anytime you
do this behavioral paradigm it slows people down
when there are arrows uh pointing in the opposite
direction of the center arrow this task has been
around for a long time and we use it um you know
in the laboratory uh and the question is what
what are we using this task for what process what
cognitive process do we think we're tapping when
we do a task like this and a cognitive ontology
the research in this area would actually formalize
this kind of question so if you had for example
so if you had one individual who says well this
is a response inhibition test that's what we're
measuring here the cognitive construct of response
inhibition and then you might have another
scientist say no what we're really looking at when
we ask people to do this is error detection that's
what i think the flanker task is mapping and in
what we do when we look at cognitive ontology
research is formalize this type of disagreement
into a research program where um you know we can
say well let's figure out what it what cognitive
construct or process is this task really tapping
and how do we get to the answer to that question
uh what what is a way to sort of uh create a
better cognitive ontology or categorization of
these mental and uh psychological constructs
so there's several approaches for constructing
cognitive ontologies and they can sort of broadly
fall into the category of uh bottom up top bottom
up and top down so a top-down approach is where
you would use expert knowledge and opinion
to um you know get a group of researchers
to agree well when you do this task what you're
really engaging is this cognitive construct and
now we all agree on that and we can write it
down and use it to communicate um so there's
been a lot of work in this area um using
expert opinion and topic modeling of text
in article databases you'll see some of the
references here russ podrick's group ng laird
jessica turner italia arcone have done a lot of
this work building a top-down sort of cognitive
ontology and of course the benefit to something
like that is that you can you know produce a
detailed ontology of relationships and entities
but there is of course the downside that this may
fail to map onto actual divisions or categories
of nature and uh and there's some other downsides
that i'll mention in in a minute but um this has
been one sort of popular approach for construction
of a cognitive ontology and on the other hand
you have this bottom-up approaches it's usually
a data-driven or more informatics-based approach
so data-driven classification or clustering of
functional imaging or behavioral data and you
can also you know use supervised machine learning
for this type of thing or exploratory unsupervised
machine learning um and uh this this bottom-up
approach basically um you know can try to derive
cognitive processed categories of cognitive
processes directly from task fmri patterns and the
pros of this is that this an ontology derived in
this manner might more likely reflect actual
divisions or categories of nature that we see
but they may not necessarily provide enough detail
to be a practical use for knowledge representation
so um you know every sort of approach has
has its pros and cons so one example just to
you know that many people might be familiar with
is of a top-down approach is this research domain
criteria that the national institute of health
has um sort of put forth and this is a way uh
it's a sort of a call for new ways of classifying
mental illness that are based on dimensions of
observable behavior and neurobiological measures
um and other measures and this is uh just a real
um kind of summary of some of the categories
within the research domain criteria uh back
in 2016 i was part of this cognitive group
the blue group here in the middle um that
basically it was a group of experts who decided
what the categories were that um would be of use
for study um you know to standardize across uh
psychiatric disorders and uh to push forward
uh personalized medicine and so forth um and being
on the panel of you know on this top down panel
made me realize sort of firsthand what were
some of the downsides of doing the top-down
approach and one of them is of course everyone who
studies uh cognitive neuroscience has their own
biases and their own sort of lifetime of of ways
of thinking about things and so expert based
approaches are prone to the kinds of biases that
experts have so you may be a person who studies
executive function so you think these particular
aspects of cognition are the most important or
the most salient or the most interesting for
investigation doesn't necessarily mean that's
the way the brain is carved up or that's the way
that the mind works but um so you know that this
was a top-down kind of ontological approach um
but the reason that this sort of research domain
criteria has been so popular is that the goal was
to carve up psychiatric disorders in a way that's
not just symptom-based so it's not just you see
a person with observable symptoms in this manner
and you put them into major depression or bipolar
or some other category because you know of course
symptoms themselves cannot tell you much about
the underlying mechanism so perhaps if you look at
genetic risks brain activity physiology behavior
and life experience and derived data-driven
clusters of individuals who were more similar
within cluster than a cross-cluster um those
those people might not all fall into the category
of major depressive disorder but they might all
be most uh well treated by a particular type
of of drug or intervention because once you've
identified clusters that are more homogeneous the
treatment and kind of response research can be
more targeted and hopefully more uh efficient so
rdoc has really prompted individuals in the field
of psychiatry to rethink how psychopathology
might be best served by building a framework
that's based more on biological and cognitive
validity so you know a lot of people working
with the rdoc framework now look for research
findings that cut across diagnostic boundaries
and uh you know this is all towards the sort of
goal of precision medicine so you can see why you
know despite there being flaws in the top-down
approach there there's been a lot of success
with this uh method and um there's been a lot of
work uh this was from russ paul drake and talia
irconi trying to derive things like cognitive
atlases which carve up the space of uh you know
of all the different cognitive constructs in
a way that lets us use a common language to
communicate about them so this cognitive atlas
project is basically a collaborative knowledge
building project aimed at developing an ontology
characterizing the current state of cognitive
neuroscience um and so this nice paper uh
summarizes some of the constructs you see all the
time cognitive control working memory executive uh
you know function and what tasks measure them um
that tasks that we use as scientists um and sort
of how the different things map onto each other
based on basically what the field is already doing
so this is just a summary of what is actually
going on in cognitive psychology and cognitive
neuroscience and cognitive sciences more broadly
um and as you can see uh this you know similar to
what ardoc is trying to do the goal here is that
if you uh you know understand a particular process
like response inhibition um which we then map onto
a brain region which we think well the trilateral
prefrontal cortex seems to be involved um then you
can look at things like signaling pathways genes
that contribute to uh function of those regions
and then at the highest level syndromes in
which that particular function is disrupted
and cutting across different diagnoses as well so
all these projects kind of get at the same goal
of relating biological functions and processes
eventually to things like psychiatric syndromes
a similar effort is called the cognitive paradigm
ontology put forth by jessica turner and angela
laird and this was based on a drawing from the
taxonomy of the brain map project which many
of you are probably familiar with the brain map
database includes uh coordinates from you know
thousands and thousands of task activation
studies that have been coded in particular ways
and what the cognitive paradigm ontology
does is represent the characteristics of
the cognitive paradigms that have been used in
fmri literature over the years so this is a uh
the brain map database itself
includes these categories like
the experimental paradigm that was used and
the type of stimulus the response type um
you know uh all these different sort of categories
um that are used to characterize the broad you
know the broad database of fmri studies that
are available today so this is another sort of
a way of organizing what's what's out there
um and this is just one example that i like
why am i going backwards there we go
another example i like of uh trying to
identify cognitive components from neuroimaging
work um from thomas joe's group and uh here he
um basically used an author topic hierarchical
vision modeling uh approach to apply this to
contrast from the brain map database to derive
what he's called here cognitive components that um
you know may contribute to performance of specific
tasks like working memory or attention tests
and a very nice sort of mapping between experiment
tasks cognitive components and the brain regions
involved this is very interesting paper that i
recommend for for those who want more on this
topic the reason i particularly like this paper
is because he he quantified what brain regions
use the most number of cognitive components
and really interestingly there's the areas
here in red you see one of them is the anterior
insula is basically activated in many many many
tasks and paradigms and experiments and as you can
see it's it's got a very high number of cognitive
components a lot of my work uh in the lab that
i'm not going to be talking about today focuses
on the role of the anterior insulin brain network
dynamics and i think it's just very interesting
that you can use completely data-driven approaches
to show the same thing that we've been doing
using things like meta-analytic connectivity
modeling and dynamic functional connectivity
looking at the flexibility of the insular
region and here you can see the flexibility
uh here is associated with the fact that this
region just participates in all kinds of uh all
manner of tasks so really interesting findings um
and so what we uh you know what i'm gearing up to
tell you about today is some of the work that
uh taylor bolt in the lab did when he was a phd
student and he left the lab a few years ago and
is now a data scientist at deloitte but he's still
publishing with us even though he uh he's taken
a position in industry so um really fantastic and
interesting work for his dissertation here where
he began a project that was sort of a data mining
cognitive ontology discovery project looking at
these task fmri data repositories with the goal of
mining them to look for clues of how patterns
of bold activity might delineate categories of
psychological function following up on some of
the you know the work that i showed you on the
introductory work that i showed you and the
goals of um this project here that was done
in collaboration with andrew laird and simon
eichoff and others i think this just came out
in neuroinformatics in 2020 the goal here was to
identify data-driven uh dimensions of a potential
ontology based upon the ability of that ontology
to explain variability between patterns of brain
activity and the approach he took here was a
whole brain representational similarity analysis
to quantify spatial similarity among task
activation maps within brain map and here the
assumption is that important features of existing
ontological categories um could be identified in
terms of the amount of how much variance they
explain in task activation map similarities
so that was the um you know the goal in
this project so what he actually did in this
set of analyses was applied an
unsupervised clustering approach
to all the task activation patterns that could
be derived from the date frame map database
coordinates and here this analysis included
15 over 15 000 activation maps that yielded
almost 9 000 contrasts that's contrast between
um you know different conditions in an fmri test
and they were all of course derived from
activation peak coordinates that are what
are available in the brain map database and um
this involved a data driven dimension reduction
and a multivariate distance matrix regression
so um so basically we started here with
this is an unsupervised clustering approach
applied to the entire corpus of the reported
activation coordinates in the brainmap database
and he began here with the construction of
uh activation maps from these reported
peak coordinates of task fmri studies
um and then a dimension reduction step
um dementia result reduction of these
voxel level maps to a smaller set of networks
using sparse non-negative matrix factorization
and then a clustering of uh basically an
activation map by activation map similarity
matrix based on the similarities and network and
activation estimates between the different uh
activation maps from these coordinates so there
are there were two goals on one was sort of to
identify how closely the uh the labels in
the brain map database really explained
differences in task activation patterns across
this huge database and the second goal was to
see if we could use a more bottom-up approach to
derive latent categories directly from the data
so um the way this worked um well interestingly
the unsupervised clustering of all these um brain
map activation maps uh yielded a four cluster
solution that achieved the most replicability
using a cross-validation approach and this
four-cluster solution could be sort of divided
up into these broad categories of tasks uh object
viewing complex action affect introspection social
and auditory motor um but note um of course
these sort of four clusters um showed a lot of
overlapping the activation maps that were
associated with them so um you know the the
only cluster that didn't look a lot like the
others was the affect social cluster which uh
resembled a little bit uh the default mode network
which we'll talk about in a bit but what this
type of analysis suggests that the um the current
those i forgot to mention that the the current
labels in the brain map database didn't um explain
as much of the variance in the test activation map
as these latent clusters so this suggests that the
current descriptions of cognitive processes and
the tasks used to elicit them do not necessarily
reflect activation patterns commonly observed
in the human brain and this is just to to note
that yeah the four data driven latent dimensions
explained a greater variation among activation
maps than all the conventional labels that were
already present in the brain map database that
were used uh to categorize the tasks in the
brainmap database and this is just showing that
the sort of task uh you know the default mode and
the negatively correlated frontal parietal systems
it's sort of a ubiquitous pattern that you see in
you know resting state fmri as well we'll get
back to that um a little bit later in the talk
um and this is just a little
bit more of a view of the four
um uh activation profiles and the associated uh
constructs with each of them and this will be
probably not so easy to read here but you can find
the full table in the paper if you're interested
um it's just another view of the cluster one two
three and four in terms of the different task
paradigms and different constructs that seem to
be associated with these types of activation maps
and this was just a you know on the left showing
you how we determined the number of clusters and
there was both a four and a seven cluster solution
that showed high levels of of stability but if you
look here on the right the um the four cluster
solution and the seven cluster solution derived
in a data-driven manner really uh explained more
variants than the traditional brain map labels on
the bottom which are behavioral domain and test
paradigm for example um so the basically the
similar similarity matrices here with brighter
colors within the red lines and cooler colors
outside are showing you that the um they're sort
of more well separated groups of task activation
maps in the top two matrices than in the bottom
two meaning that the cluster solution that he
derived in a data-driven fashion was better able
to explain differences in activation maps than
the labels that have been provided already by the
users in the brain map database so in summary here
task paradigm which is one of the categories that
that brainwave database includes seemed to explain
more variants among test activation patterns
than other dimensions um including the latent
categories that you saw there and and this means
that like when an individual is is deciding on
particular tasks to study a particular construct
like working memory for example that which
paradigm they choose can be very important because
different test paradigm as a category explains a
lot of the variants among these activation maps
study id which is what you know which study the
activation maps came from actually explains
about 50 of variance and activation patterns
um and the data derived late inactivation states
uh we saw here um were associated with kind of
known functional systems from frontal parietal
um salient sensory motor and default activation
patterns and those four data driven latent
dimensions appear to explain greater variance
among activation maps than all the conventional
ontological dimensions combined so these are um
just some clues that that just because we
think well we have a working memory task
or we call it a working memory task um you know
it doesn't necessarily share activation patterns
with other things that are called working memory
tasks and in fact the uh the labels that we've
been using all along um you know may need to
be revisited and if we're really looking for
things that explain great variants amongst brain
activation patterns then the current categories
um that are used the current labels that are
used don't seem to be doing a great job of that
um so that was uh there's another
kind of way to to ask this question
the first analysis was trying to classify
activation maps into separable categories
um and and you know have you know separable
clusters but not sort of account for commonalities
um between them so there was a lot of overlap
in the clusters i just showed you however
um that's because the goal of a this that
unsupervised clustering algorithm was to
highlight the differences among the maps not the
commonalities so the next goal was to sort of
explore the commonalities that were observed in an
exploratory model and here um what he chose to do
was a bi-factor analysis to explicitly model a
general commonality that could exist across all
activation maps while allowing for subclusters
to emerge within this general pattern um and
um and this analysis oops yeah so this
analysis uh required us to accurately
estimate similarities and differences between
activation maps and the p-coordinate meta-analysis
you know that that is permitted by brain
map wasn't quite sufficient for this job
what we really wanted here was unthresholded
activation maps and we found those available
in the neurovault database as well as the
human connectome project those are two
places where unthresholded active whole brain
activation maps are available so um you know
using all the task fmr activation maps available
in neurovault and in the human connectome project
yielded 108 activation maps across a
variety of task domains that we could
use in order to to follow up
or to ask this question so um
oops okay so the approach here was to
first do a data reduction to reduce
the spatial dependence between the activation
estimates across voxels um then we uh enter
we conducted a initial extraction phase
in which an initial factor solution is
estimated and the appropriate number of factors
is determined by parallel analysis followed by
a bi-factor analysis phase in which the factor
analysis is re-estimated with estimated number
of factors from the initial extraction phase
and a bi-factor rotation criteria and finally
testing the fit of other alternative factor
structures using confirmatory factor analysis
so um how did this work so this is just a test
activation conjunction and test deactivation
conjunction across all those maps and as sort of a
sanity check you can see a lot of frontal parietal
and um you know insular and cingulate systems
are activated across all tasks and deactivated
default mode network regions uh you
know as one might sort of expect so um
so basically um the first step was a data
reduction as i mentioned and um this was sort
of followed up by the bi-factor analysis approach
where each task activation map representing
um activation uh here in red associated with a
particular task is modeled as arising from direct
effects of a single latent general factor and
various lane sub factors so this was a way of sort
of first accounting for all the commonalities we
see across the task activation maps regardless of
task as well as sort of sub um you know activation
or sub factors that account for differences among
different task activation patterns so this results
of this five factor analysis suggests a general
factor which explained over 50 percent of the
variance in the activation maps and again it
looks very familiar to um sort of task positive
test negative or default mode and you know front
to parietal systems that we see sort of across all
kinds of both tasks and rest paradigms but within
the you know in addition to this general factor we
saw as well subtypes which explained an additional
31 percent of the variance in activation maps
um so um you know this is suggests that uh that
there is sort of a hierarchical structure to
these um these patterns that we we have observed
so what else do we know about this pattern of
you know the sort of midline regions um with the
lateral frontal parietal regions so this kind of
lateral frontal parietal system is independently
described as a multiple demand system or domain
general test system or the extrinsic mode or the
executive control system it just goes by a lot of
names and i'll bring up this point again in a few
slides about what i think about the problem of
all this nomenclature and then there's the sort
of midline regions that are often described as
a default mode network and of course there's
seems to be antagonist antagonistic relationships
between these sets of systems and the the pattern
um that you see is pretty ubiquitous if you look
at um you know if you look at uh gradients of
functional connectivity here on the left with
margulies if you look at co-activation pattern
analysis um you know if you look at the posterior
cingulate and its co-activation again you get this
default mode network if you look at correlations
of brain areas with amplitude of eg alpha rhythm
um this pattern of sort of lateral frontal
parietal versus medial frontal parietal regions
is ubiquitous across different analysis techniques
research questions tasks or resting stata from rye
so this shows that the single activation pattern
dominating uh most observed tests and from our
activation maps is is uh this positive negative
pattern we've seen over and over again um and
any cognitive ontology derived from an exploratory
analysis of task fmri activation map seems to be
it should be dominated by this pattern so
understanding what this pattern represents
is i think essential for any cognitive ontology
or any construction of a set of um you know basic
principles by which cognition uh is organized
in terms of um underlying brain activation
and that um all of this brings me to our sort of
current work which uh centers more around uh brain
networks and cognitive neuroscience so i've been
talking a lot about individual brain areas that
are activated or not in response to specific
cognitive tasks or specific instructions or
specific paradigms but what our lab really focuses
on a lot these days is network approaches and
network neuroscience um and understanding that you
know brain regions don't really work in isolation
right um and you have sort of patterns of
frequent co-activation and patterns of functional
connectivity that um are sort of underlying a lot
of what you see when you look at task fmri data
and one thing um we've sort of been trying to
tackle in our recent uh work is this problem
that you people refer to different brain
regions belonging to different brain networks
in a way that's not at all standardized um
for example you know for a region like the
anterior insula um you can look at the cognitive
neuroscience literature and find people saying
well the anterior insulin is part of the singular
circular network the anterior slowest part of the
stainless steel work the anterior so it's part
of a ventral attention network um and they may
also ascribe um overlapping yet unique roles for
these uh brain regions within these networks so um
you know i see this as a problem for the field in
terms of developing a common language developing
taxonomies that we can use to communicate amongst
ourselves um so how how are we going to define a
functional brain network given we don't have this
consensus at present and how many functional brain
networks are there these are of course ill-posed
questions but they're sort of what's uh keeping us
up at night right so um you know i started to do
this work with thomas yo and nathan spring uh last
year where we tried to move towards developing
a universal taxonomy of macroscale functional
human brain networks i mean i think this just
relates a lot to the work that's being done in the
um construction of cognitive ontologies i think
for obvious reasons and this was a an initial stab
at this difficult question that we took um and
this was just the stance that if we start to use
similar terminology across studies we may really
make progress in terms of of of human brain
mapping and if we don't have conventions and we
don't have consistent nomenclature it will just
hinder future progress in this field so luckily um
i was able to convince the new ohbm best practices
committee that what we really need is to have a
committee of individuals working on this topic who
have worked in connectivity who have worked
in um meta-analysis and worked in anatomy
to come together and see if we can have reach
a consensus of sorts on this really important
nomenclature issue so the first thing um you know
we did initially was just look at what's already
out there and um almost every like independent
component analysis or brain parcellation or um you
know connectivity modeling approach meta-analytic
approach almost everything identifies something
with a visual back-of-the-brain network as you
can see and here's steve smith work on the left
comparing resting state networks to the brain map
data base meta-analyses on the right thomas use
you know well-known functional parcellation of
the brain on the bottom one by evan gordon and
you can see there's always seems to be something
called a visual network or an occipital network so
maybe that should be one of the things we include
in our taxonomy of networks when we eventually
build one um you can also almost always see
something like a somatosensory or somatomotor
or um you know motor cortex network you can
see it in resting state parcellations here
on different resolutions and you know if you
obviously parcellate the brain into smaller and
smaller bits you can subdivide these networks into
subsystems so this seems to be you know a place we
can start and then you get into these higher level
cognitive association areas there's been what's
been called the dorsal attention network from many
years of cognitive neuroscience research showing
that sort of top-down attention engages these
frontal eye field and posterior parietal areas
and meta-analytic connectivity modeling
suggests that something like this exists
and you can see in green the dorsal attention
network comes out in several different
parsolations of the whole brain um so these are we
think some starting points um this one and as we
get further along we get into more controversial
perhaps and less agreed upon um nomenclatures
but you you know people talk about executive
control central executive multiple demand
as i mentioned um this this network seems to have
a lot of names um on the right it's uh classified
as frontal parietal and uh on the left these are
from um executive individuals who refer to these
networks as executive control or central executive
networks uh so there just needs to be a little bit
more um agreement upon what label we should use to
to describe systems or activations or connectivity
within these regions and here's one that's you
know close to my heart and also very controversial
um you know in my work i've called the insular acc
network the salience network and but there seems
to be a lot of overlap anatomically with what's
been called the ventral attention network as well
as the singular particular network um and there
seems to be a lot more variability in terms of the
spatial topography here and uh you know this one
will be a difficult one to come to a consensus on
but the nomenclature that we're proposing here
is is more anatomical based and less and more
agnostic with regards to what we think the actual
function is so if we see mid-singular insular you
know connectivity or activation we might just say
okay well that's a midsingulated solar network
and that will prompt us to um you know more
consistently identify this uh in future work
um and this of course the default mode network
everybody has known about for many years
and we're even proposing to rename that as a
medial frontal parietal network with the idea that
sticking with the anatomical
terms will help us moving forward
and of course you see fractionation
within this network you see subsystems
it's not a sort of monolithic entity so this is
where a lot of work needs to be done to parse that
and what we should call these subsystems for
example so you know this is one example of a i
would say this was a top-down approach at deriving
a taxonomy of functional brain networks this is
the initial uh breakdown that we observe or
that we agreed upon but again the reason we
formed the current best practices committee
was because we really need sort of wholesale
buy-in from the community in order to make any
taxonomy work so it doesn't really make sense
for me to call something amid singular and solar
network in a paper if no one else is adopting
that terminology and no one else knows what i'm
talking about so these are some of the ongoing
challenges and goals for our current best
practice committee on network nomenclature
and why we still need to refine this taxonomy it
should be obvious i gave a twitter talk on this
a few months back about what about network
dynamics what about inter-individual variability
and activation and connectivity what about
subcortical brain regions what about the idea
that networks fractionate into subsystems and the
hierarchies i just talked to you about what about
these hierarchies these are all things that you
know require a lot of discussion and so the group
we have assembled is now meeting once a month to
hopefully tackle these issues and see where we get
and i think one of the things that will make
this program or this uh goal hard to achieve
is that networks don't just kind of stay in one
place and do the same thing from moment to moment
um there's really a nice theoretical paper by
marshall messellembeck from the 90s talking about
how cognition is subserved by interconnected
neural networks and complex behaviors mapped
at the level of multifocal neural systems
rather than specific anatomical sites so even
you know back in the day before fmri we knew that
it wasn't as simple as one brain region does one
cognitive process you know multiple brain
regions contribute to multiple processes
um and you could see that even with uh you know a
neuropsychological approach we also know that the
function of a brain region and brain area can
often depend on the status of other connected
areas this was the idea of of neural context put
forth by randy macintosh so a set of nodes here
for example the gray nodes um might behave in a
particular way uh when the black nodes are there
activated but behave in a different way when the
the black nodes in b are activated so this context
is important for the function um and lastly
something we're very interested in is dynamics
and how regions change raid regions change
their affiliation over time in the matter of uh
you know seconds and probably even milliseconds um
and so a network of course needs to be understood
in terms of the interactions between multiple
brain regions as they unfold temporally so i think
because of all of these issues uh with respect
to dynamics and many to many mapping of brain
region to function all of these issues will make
it really difficult to arrive at a taxonomy or
um you know ontology of brain networks but
you know nevertheless will will uh persist
so this is uh you know just a short overview
of how i think neuroinformatics can contribute
to the formation of cognitive ontologies
this work was really done by taylor bolt um
and you know congrats to him for uh pushing our
lab into this direction um and angie laird has
been a great collaborator um simon eichoff thomas
joe and nathan spring um and of course the funding
sources have um you know made this uh you know
all possible in many ways so i wanted to just
close by saying um you know vote like your life
depends on it because that's been the only thing
on my mind for the last few weeks and i just
thought um if we haven't yet um please do and
this is our you know the only hope that keeps
us going at this point and uh now i'm in san
diego on sabbatical so this is um this is my
sort of morning view and uh i'm i'm happy to
to leave the rest of the time for questions and
and want to say thanks again very much for this
kind of invitation and for uh providing me the
opportunity to share some of this this work that
i've been very excited about i'm happy to take any
questions now i'll hand it back over to you jack
thank you lucina that was a fantastic overview
of cognitive ontologies many of the challenges
which exist and uh it's just uh an area which i
have observed either either been involved with
those discussions or observed for many years and
you're absolutely right it's a very challenging
problem um and one of the things i think you kind
of i want to encourage our data science innovation
lab participants to send in any questions via the
chat but while we're waiting for a few um i was
very you you touched on a couple of key things you
have the kind of the expert opinion about how the
ontology ought to be constructed and um i remember
you mentioned russ poldrack a number of times and
he's a a colleague and friend and he's mentioned
to me uh several times it's uh trying to get a
bunch of psychologists to agree on what to call
things you can maybe get them to agree on the top
most layer of the ontology but you get about two
layers in and it becomes a probabilistic fog of
what people are gonna call it and um so there's
this sort of lack of consensus with regard to
these um kind of psychological constructs and
you kind of mentioned some things about the um
uh the uh um what did i have in my notes
kind of the labeling of various tasks
and this sort of reminded me of you know what you
call something and what it actually measures maybe
two different things this notion like construct
validity um what is your feeling about how we
can kind of clean some of that up in order to make
some of these challenges a little more attractive
yeah i mean that's exactly you hit the nail on
the head i know you've been working in this area
as well over the years and we're sort of new
to it so i i haven't tried to do the difficult
task um that you know russ and others have been
doing which is to try to get scientists to agree
that okay this task measures this construct and
um and you know this one instead measures that
i haven't been involved in those discussions
and um and to be completely honest the the bit
that i have like in the construction of the
rdoc cognitive domain it's been frustrating
because so much of it is ego driven you know
if you spent your 20 years of your career
building up a task to study working memory and
suddenly someone tells you well if you look at it
this way it's not really studying that at all it's
studying this other thing i think people are often
really um loathed to give up their favorite task
or to concede that they're not measuring a pure
construct the way they thought they were so that i
think that has to sort of give way a little bit to
but what do the data tell us you know uh the
kind of thing taylor was doing it looking at
similarity across activation maps is one way
to do it like if if they're measuring similar
things do they activate you know uh similar brain
regions that's one way of thinking about it right
um so but you know it's not the only way of
course they're just because regions are activated
similarly doesn't mean there isn't a pattern
within there that could differ differentiate
um so as many people know there's there's a lot
of patterns within boxes of activation that could
again be discriminative so um i feel like everyone
you know the field we all need to kind of take a
step back and say well is the goal to be right
about what is working memory or is the goal to
come to a consensus where we can all speak
a common language and move forward and
and uh you know be a little bit more um clear
in in what we're saying when we use a particular
terminology so i actually do think
we're getting towards that but um slowly
it sounds like an advertisement for the use
of data science to help some of this stuff
out doesn't it i would say that yeah one of the
things which is kind of interesting and maybe you
have a comment on this as well is that um a lot of
these data driven or computational topic modeling
type approaches um they create a reality from what
they're given yeah and we see these biases creep
in we see this kind of particularly um in machine
learning and ai kind of applications for like face
recognition that certain ethnic groups don't get
represented properly don't get identified in the
right way and obviously this sort of thing you
can see how this might get baked into any sort
of data science application of these very rich
uh data sets how can do you have any idea about
how some of these data-driven approaches uh for
cognition can be more robust or at least honest
about the potential biases that exist and that
might be driven by what's trendy in the literature
and you know may drive these things like you said
there's some egos involved always yeah this is a
great question that's so important for a lot of uh
reasons um in terms of equity uh and i think the
the best i mean you cannot guard against human
biases because they exist on so many levels but
what you can do is build the most diverse teams um
you know if you have programmers from all over the
world and different you know ethnic backgrounds
they'll be more likely to notice when these biases
creep into an algorithm and they'll be more likely
to test against those kinds of things so you know
having these diverse teams is is critical for
the science it's not just the right thing to do
um absolutely um one other thing is uh there's
other kinds of biases though as well um one being
like publication bias and so when you draw from a
literature or from a database that is leveraging
a lot of uh different results from around the
field you can get biases because people just
publish stuff that's statistically significant so
things that aren't significant which would greatly
inform your ontology you just don't even see them
and so again you've created a reality out of stuff
that's statistically significant is that helpful
exactly um this is the file drawer problem uh what
i've been heartened by is the um the emergence
of these new journals i think neuroimage has one
now coming out their image reports um and
aperture the new ohbm journal there's so
many journals that are now realizing the need for
reporting all results you know good bad and ugly
because that that that's what you need in order to
um get a full picture of what people are actually
finding it doesn't help if only 20 of studies get
published because those are the ones people label
as interesting it i'm more of a fan of you
know publishing everything somewhere because
publishing is the way you communicate what you did
and it just because what you did wasn't the most
exciting thing doesn't mean that other people
don't need to know that you did it absolutely
it might stop them from going down a road or it
might put them on a different path to explore
you know something that hasn't gotten a lot of
uh attention but yeah i agree with you completely
that this file drawer problem makes it hard for
data science because you can only do meta-analysis
or you can only do a data-driven approach
on data that exists or it's published so if
there were you know no there's no studies in the
brain map database that are not published right
there's a whole sociology about uh
data sharing um in neuroscience i
was the tip of the spirit of that for a little
while i could tell you horror stories but um
it's uh it's just a very interesting thing it's
i'm pleased to see these journals taking this
on and trying to do something about that i
think that's a positive step well one thing
i wanted to ask you about is um something about
the um the stability of these networks um and
how reproducible are they this is not only from a
empirical point of view and a replication point of
view but also in terms of the analytic procedure
which is used to identify them many times people
use the independent components analysis method
to be able to partition these networks into
their different components from the data um
there's some mathematical challenges though with
some of the most widely used methods which they
sort of take a guess at to the initial state of
the weighting matrix that produces the independent
components analysis result um the challenge there
is that while it may converge after that random
guess it may converge on a particular network
structure that totally satisfies the matrix
equations it's supposed to satisfy if you run
it again you'll get a different guess and you'll
get a different solution and even if you average
across all those potential uh solutions it's not
representative of what's actually going on and i
guess this uh brings to me the stability of these
and whether or not they can actually be truly
called functional networks if they vary so greatly
not only within a person but between people
right you get the idea yeah yeah it's just such a
great question it's so important i i would say it
the the bigger question here is um is almost uh
you know it's the same question of you know how
many networks are there so and that of course any
kind of uh data-driven clustering solution you can
either determine the number of clusters you can
say i want 20 independent components i want 100
independent components you can ask the algorithm
to automatically estimate the number of clusters
so it's a clustering problem as much as anything
else right so it's not unique to um brain networks
or brain regions that user defined clusters could
be one approach or you know data-driven clusters
could be another project then you have to evaluate
the stability of the clusters and you have
some metric for doing that and you might get a
different number based on which metric you use
so i think these are you know um problems that
are not unique to the question here we have
about networks um you know clustering and how
many there are what's the best solution that's a
problem generally right for anyone doing anything
like this so i then it's like which metric do you
trust enough what's amazing to me is the
um consistency of networks independent of
whether you do you know a resting state kind
of breakdown or a task meta-analysis or what's
what's what's surprising to me is that at a
given level let's say i i want 10 parcels or
10 networks at a given resolution there seems to
be a good amount of consistency between you know
different approaches and different data sets and
different techniques and not of course they're
not identical from one to the next but you know at
a given resolution it's it's a heartening to see
a good amount of um stability as it were so i mean
for example there's almost nothing you could do
there's almost no ica you could run that wouldn't
give you some kind of default mode network yeah
which is heartening it means you know something
is there it can break down certainly it can be
subdivided but you know seems like there's
something about the brain that lets it settle
into this state so you know there's hope is
what i'd like to say yeah it's uh some of the um
our participants in our data science
innovation lab are asking about the stability
and changes in these networks over the life span
and i know that you've mentioned some of the work
of michael gracias and he had done some work
kind of a long time ago now that looking at the
variation between people who have alzheimer's
disease in contrast to those who are otherwise
healthy agers in the context of their default mode
network and changes thereof do you do you see that
this is also something we should be looking
at is the changes in these networks as they
uh alter their structure over time uh 100 and you
know we do lifespan network development in my lab
is one of the things we're interested in um and
the all of the parcelations i showed you in the
last few slides are done on adult subjects and the
assumption is well that's how the brain is parsley
but of course anyone who does developmental
work knows that you have changes going from
infancy to childhood to adolescence to adulthood
um in the spatial topography and the connectivity
within in between networks these are these
are processes that develop and again change
with aging and with disease so of course this
is this is critical to understand there have
been as far as i know no attempts yet to parse
the brain in these um you know in these ways
across the lifespan in order to say well does this
parcel sort of change from childhood to adulthood
at the whole brain level i think people have
done this at like individual brain regions
um and i think i know a group in western ontario
who is working on this we're looking at age bins
let's say for example five to eight and eight to
twelve and twelve to fifteen and looking at how
whole brain organization in terms of the
parcellation changes in those um in a stepwise
manner uh there's other ways of doing it um and i
think uh the availability of large data sets to do
this kind of analysis is really what's what we're
waiting on i think there are some data sets but
you know not at the level that there are for hcp
and the other like normal adult samples so as soon
as we get more developmental samples across the
lifespan this will be super important to address
how can we integrate functional networks
with other means for measuring networks
for example diffusion tensor imaging
where you have a measure of structure
that could be used to guide and maybe inform
the functional networks that are being extracted
yeah i mean the multimodal integration part
is something that is so tricky because on the
one hand you want to say well okay these these
two approaches let's say structure and function
converge um but on the other hand why should
they converge they're measuring completely
different things you know axons versus statistical
uh relationships between fluctuations of old
signals so so when they do converge you say
great these these are telling us the same thing
when they don't there's a million reasons why
they couldn't and one thing we found early on
was that structure and function like let's say
diffusion metrics and functional connectivity
are high are seem to be very correlated in the
adult brain but when you look at children like
let's say seven to twelve there's very low
there's non-significant correlation between
structural and functional connectivity this
is something we noticed a while ago and
so something is happening you know something's
developing what comes first structure or function
you get into you know all of these chicken and egg
questions not not to say we don't care about this
but we haven't made uh progress in this or our lab
hasn't made progress in the multimodal integration
domain but i think others have vince calhoun's
group and others have really thought about this
more seriously do you think there's any sort
of uh opportunity for people who are developing
more uh comp i guess complete models of brain
networks that are more than just correlative
that this is correlated with that it's rather it's
a solution to a say a physical like a physical
network where you have you know a source and you
have a you know another source and there's a wire
between them and you could model the properties of
the wire and the signal that travels over that are
there any opportunities for those people in fact
i i before this the last international trip i took
was a conference in nepal that was a computational
neuroscience conference with you know victor yirza
and michael breakspeare and all these great people
and my plan for sabbatical was to go visit michael
breakspeare in australia and then visit gustavo
deco in barcelona that was my original plan
obviously the reason for that was because
of just what you said i think computational
modeling is the only way you can do
this um linking of different levels and
really testing what parameters affect what
you know what outputs and so my whole plan
was to spend my year instead of in san diego to
spend it with those labs in those nice locations
and and i'm hoping that the work that those
groups are doing um are going to feed into you
know these these questions of how many networks
are there and how do they change over time
because those are the only ways in which
you have complete control over all the
the different variables um and
unfortunately i'm not doing that
as you can see but that doesn't mean that
it won't be done eventually international
multi-hemispheric travel is going to have to be
put on hold on hold exactly a little while longer
i think on that note i want to thank you lucina
for uh providing us with this great overview of
this very interesting area of cognitive ontologies
and uh the role of uh data science and helping to
identify the structure and organization of these
different cognitive constructs and what that means
for the brain and for the data science that it's
going to take to be able to make some traction
um so thank you so much we really appreciate
chatting with you today thank you so such
a pleasure and uh yeah good luck to everyone
excellent and uh i want to thank everybody who
who joined us and uh we'll look forward to seeing
you uh next friday for the next edition of our uh
data science innovation lab seminar series
thank you everybody have a great weekend